but tonight there is something way more
troubling than Biden's obvious decline
for him and his family there are now
real and growing concerns that your
president the president of our country
is compromised after months of
obfuscation from the FBI and the doj
that
fd-1023 form that documented allegations
of bribery from a trusted FBI
confidential human Source has now
finally been released thanks to Senator
Chuck Grassley of Iowa now its contents
are devastating we're going to break it
all down for you with investigative
reporter John Solomon who will join us
in a moment but before we dig deeper
it's important to remember this very
important thing this is not a story
about Hunter Biden it's not about Jill
Biden it's not about Jim Biden this is
about the big guy himself Joe Biden a
corrupt career politician who is now
very credibly accused of public
corruption on a scale this country has
never seen before and having top FBI and
doj officials covering for him while
simultaneously going after his number
one opponent which we'll also get to now
this may start to sound complicated it
is not remember the FBI and the doj did
not want the house oversight committee
that's Jim Comer's committee to see the
1023 form documents about several
conversations between a barisma that's
the oil Giant in Ukraine executive and a
confidential human Source beginning in
2015. keep in mind This Confidential
Source they call a CHS was previously
paid hundreds and hundreds of thousands
of dollars by the FBI for other
information he gave them in other words
clearly the FBI believed he was a
credible source and is documented by
this 1023 form Ukrainian oil and gas
giant Barista Holdings remember they
paid Hunter Biden a massive amount of
money to sit on their board he had no
experience in oil gas coal energy or
Ukraine they wanted him uh not for his
experience but quote they hired Hunter
Biden to protect us through his dad from
all kinds of problems now this
apparently included a proposed expansion
into the U.S market but according to the
FBI's confidential human Source we now
have the document barisma CEO told him
quote don't worry Hunter will take care
of all those issues through his dad now
remember at the time Hunter's dad Joe
Biden was the Vice President in charge
of policy in Ukraine and one of the big
problems that baristma was facing
stemmed from a prosecutor we know his
name Victor shulkin who was
investigating the company and Hunter for
corruption lo and behold and early 2016
Joe Biden goes through Ukraine he
leveraged a whopping 1 billion U.S tax
dollars that was going to be given in
loan guarantees and demanded in return
forced Ukraine to fire the prosecutor in
six hours before he left and Son of a
bee that they fired the guy they fired
him within six hours and guess what Joe
bragged about it all on tape and Hunter
kept being paid a fortune even admitting
on Good Morning America we played it
many times that he had no experience now
according to the claims that are
documented in this 1023 form well help
from the bidens did not come cheaply
quote it costs five million dollars to
pay one Biden and five Millions uh to
another Biden the barisma executive
quote stated he didn't want to pay the
bidens he was pushed to pay them and
according to these claims they weren't
paying Hunter for his intellect or
experience in fact the document refers
to Hunter as stupid over and over and
over again if you do crack you're pretty
stupid anyway at one point Barista CEO
allegedly claimed that his dog was
smarter than Hunter Biden
didn't make that up and they needed to
keep Hunter on the board so quote
everything will be okay does that sound
like a quid pro quo anyway we saw the
same situation in China remember Hunter
is now Infamous WhatsApp Shakedown he
wasn't selling experience he wasn't
selling any type of expertise uh he was
selling access to his father and in this
case to a prominent Chinese businessman
remember he said in the WhatsApp that's
one of those Secret app things that
people use so nobody can find it anyway
quote I'm sitting here with my father
and would like to understand why the
commitment made has not been fulfilled
Hunter continued I will make certain
that between the man sitting next to me
and every person that he knows and my
ability to hold the grudge that you will
regret not following my direction I'm
sitting here waiting for the call with
my father
amazingly shockingly I can't believe it
the Biden's actually had five million
dollars within a week right after the
message and that money came from that
guy's company now keep in mind according
to material found on Hunter Biden's real
laptop his father the big guy apparently
due to make 10 percent from one of
Hunter's business deals on the laptop
again Hunter bitterly complained about
having a fork over half of his income
and salary to Pops there are also
numerous pictures of Biden meeting with
Hunter's Farm business partners now uh I
don't work for the FBI but it doesn't
really seem like Joe played a real
integral role doesn't it seem like it in
his son's business deals uh because
here's the sad part upper management
within our department of justice and our
FBI not the rank and file the FBI Rank
and file brave people to put their lives
on the line and protect our our country
I'm not blaming them but the people at
the top in the doj and the FBI were
protecting the entire Biden family and
yet Biden swore over and over again when
he was running that he never one time
ever ever ever
discussed foreign business dealings with
his son why did Joe lie to the entire
country about that now even the most
pompous Biden Fanboy in the house had
accidentally yesterday admitted that Joe
knew all about his son's Farm business
ventures take a look
you testified that he said to to that
Hunter told his dad according to Rob
Walker quote I may be trying to start a
company or try to do something with
these guys
now let me ask you something that
doesn't sound much like Joe Biden was
involved in whatever Hunter Biden was
doing with the cefc if Hunter Biden is
telling him that he's trying to do
business with them does it
no but it does show that he said he told
his father he was trying to do business
and he was okay well that is true Hunter
Biden does try to do business that's
correct yeah that's correct he was doing
more than trying Hunter was making a ton
of money millions of dollars in fact at
the same time he was not even registered
as the law requires as a foreign agent
uh those are part of the Farah laws
remember they charged Paul manafort with
that he wasn't paying taxes on much of
that money and he was even deducting
money spent on hookers and sex club
memberships from his taxes according to
the IRS whistleblowers now the FBI and
the doj had little interest in even
pursuing these charges and as reported
by the editor-in-chief of just
thenews.com John Solomon the feds gave
the Biden family a heads up prior to an
IRS interview they had planned with
Hunter and ultimately that interview was
blocked and after a five-year
investigation started by the IRS the doj
managed only two misdemeanor tax
violations after felony tax violations
were recommended and then they slow
walked it to the point where the statute
of limitations ran out on many years of
monies that they were taking in serious
charges the FBI and the doj they're not
supposed to be in the business of
protecting crackheads and corrupt
politicians from prosecution so this is
all not only pretty weird it's corrupt
until you remember it's not about Hunter
anymore instead it's about your
President Joe Biden the big guy himself
and the lengths to which the federal
government will go to protect their
Golden Goose they protected Hillary they
protect the bidens and they charged
Donald Trump for spitting on the
sidewalk and jaywalking and as John
Solomon points out the bureau's Former
Intelligence Chief believes that the
memo warrants a criminal investig
negotiation of the president of the
United States Joe Biden I agree with
that but tonight without evidence the
White House is referring to all of these
charges and allegations as debunked you
mean you didn't lie to us when you said
you never talked to Hunter's business
partners and the FBI referred to the
release of the 1023 form as unnecessary
and dangerous hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else